welcome back to CBS this morning one of
Jeffrey Epstein's accusers who said she
has an inside view of his world is
giving us disturbing new details of what
happened
Maria farmer was a young artist in the
1990s when she met Epstein she and her
younger sister Annie claim Epstein
sexually assaulted them and farmer is
now suing Epstein estate over the
alleged incident farmer says she was the
first known accuser to alert law
enforcement to Epstein a decade before
his first arrest in her first TV
interview farmer talks about why she's
still seeking justice
even after Epstein's death I want people
to know that these women are strong and
they're still standing the women Maria
farmer started drawing this month are
all alleged victims of Jeffrey Epstein
she sketched seven so far including her
younger sister I turned for a long time
think about them and then I decided I
can't ignore it anymore I'm gonna draw
them I'm gonna paint them I'm gonna
glorify them she'd been unable to paint
for more than 20 years she says after
her own alleged assault by Epstein and
his close friend Gillen Maxwell that's
what Gillen and Jeffrey did they took
away the thing I was supposed to do and
they did that to everybody
farmer was a promising young artist when
she says she met Epstein and Maxwell at
an Art Show in New York City in 1995
Epstein bought this painting of hers
that night and she says eventually
offered her a job the 26-year old soon
found herself working the front desk in
his palatial New York City townhouse did
you see young women coming into the
house yes I saw many many many many many
all day long all day long I saw a
gillian going to get the women she went
to places like Central Park I was with
her a couple times in the car she would
say stop the car and she would dash out
and get a child what did she say she was
doing what she did this getting
Victoria's Secret models farmer found
Epstein's behavior mysterious one day I
said to Jeffrey what goes on in this
house like why are you always upstairs
and he said I'll show you and so he took
me up there in the
elevator and we went he showed me all of
Gillan's quarters she had her own suite
in the house oh [ __ ] a whole floor
ultimately farmer says Epstein led her
to his bathroom and there's a marble
like altar thing over here and he said
that's where he gets his massages
Epstein told her the whole house was
wired with pinhole cameras and took her
into the media room where they were
monitored I looked on the cameras and I
saw toilet toilet bed bed toilet bed I'm
like I am never gonna use the restroom
here and I'm never gonna sleep here was
there video tab oh it was all video all
the time yeah and and I asked him one
time what do you do with this and he
said I keep it I keep everything in my
safe in the summer of 1996 farmer says
Epstein sent her to be an artist in
residence on the vast estate of Les
Wexner the CEO of Elle brands which owns
Victoria's Secret how would you describe
Epstein's relationship with Wexler
Epstein told me what their relationship
was he said Wexner would do anything for
him he bragged about it the estate she
says was heavily guarded by armed
security and dogs she stayed in what she
was told was the guest house did you
ever see him no I called Wexner The
Wizard of Oz he was the one behind the
curtain cut out all the power on the
night this photograph was taken by
Maxwell farmer alleges in her complaint
that Maxwell and Epstein sexually
assaulted her there how are you doing at
that moment oh I was hysterical farmer
alleges in her complaint that when she
tried to flee the following day she was
not allowed to leave she claims a member
of wexner staff warned her his exact
words were you're not going anywhere you
are never leaving you are never leaving
farmers says she escaped only after
calling her father for help in a
statement the wexner said they had no
knowledge a farmer never met her never
spoke with her and the guesthouse where
farmer says she stayed was not a Wexner
guesthouse farmer alleges Maxwell
threatened to destroy her reputation in
the art world and in one phone call she
believes
and her life she says you're going out
to jog on the West Side Highway every
day and I know this you need to be very
careful cuz there's so many ways to die
there she should be really careful look
over your shoulder farmer says she
reported the assault to the FBI but she
told us it wasn't for another decade
just before Epstein's first arrest in
2006 that an agent finally appeared at
her door farmer says they never followed
up they still haven't asked to talk to
me they are trying to pretend I do not
exist that's right
I want my report and I want it printed
out so I can show everyone how much they
failed I don't know if I'll ever get it
we've been requesting it forever is this
getting any easier at all for you this
is not getting easier right now I
believe it will get easier once I do the
paintings I think that's gonna be my
therapy she's still waiting for justice
but in painting her fellow survivors
Maria farmer has finally found her art
again because I'm healing myself through
this process no one's gonna do it for me
so those paintings being a lot - they do
these women mean a lot to me Elaine
Maxwell has not been charged with any
crime and it has denied any wrongdoing
we asked farmer where her portrait is
among those women she says she is not
painting herself and instead will
display a blank sheet of white paper
captioned this is how the FBI sees me
wow I didn't think this tour could get
any clearer
Gil a Maxwell is still very fast to name
no one is hurt no one denies where she
but her name keeps coming up and good
for miss farmer for speaking out the way
she's yeah she hopes to have a show of
all these paintings of all the women
that she's doing she's got interest from
a gallery in Los Angeles and I asked her
I said about this suit I said you expect
to get any money and she said no I don't
I said so why are you doing it he should
to let them know I'm a person I'm here I
exist and I count maybe that blank paint
painting for the FBI would be filled out
she accused all nurses all right Anthony